Lior Aviram, thank you for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I am well, considering these corona days.
Pleasure to be with you.
I mean, I'm saying,
I was about to say good morning,
but it's actually your evening soon.
Even though the sun
still seems to shine.
You're in Israel right now, right?
Right. Right.
And the sun is setting right behind me.
That's wonderful. That's wonderful.
Lior, it's a privilege to have you.
It's an honor to have you.
Because your 25 years of experience
in the legal field,
and within Shibolet,
and within high tech,
as a young entrepreneur
coming into this journey,
even though I do get exposed
to venture capital quite a bit now,
seeing the legal side of things
and understanding the complexity of things
that go into the life cycle of a startup
to M&As, to investments,
it's something that's almost like
a big black box to a lot of entrepreneurs.
Not just young entrepreneurs,
I'm assuming.
And what I'd love to do in this discussion
is dumb it down for me.
And I want to explore, what are the things
that I can be curious about?
What are the things that I maybe
shouldn't be curious about?
And what are the biggest pitfalls
that I can avoid as a young entrepreneur?
But before that, Lior, just,
I'd like to know who you are.
And take me a little bit
through your journey
of going into the high tech.
Already in the early 90s,
as you mentioned before,
it was considered high tech.
Right, right.
So, I started doing high tech
before there was an Israeli high tech.
Just because, before in 1990
there were no venture capital in Israel.
So, I was lucky enough
just by coincidence,
like all good things in life,
or lucky enough,
to be among the lawyers that started
to work with VCs early 90s.
We actually needed to invent
the subject in Israel.
So, what we did is, took the books
of the MVCA from California.
And translated them into Hebrew,
not in the language linguistic sense,
but in the legal sense.
And it was quite an experience
because just to then negotiate
and explain to the other lawyers in Israel
why you need preferred shares,
and all those issues that are just,
you know that, everyone knows that.
But then it was like something,
like a revolution.
You hear their revolution.
It's literally pioneering a lot of these
formal definitions and communications
between the different parties.
And it must have been quite an experience.
What made you
going to that side of high tech?
So, as you're getting exposed
to these different things,
you choose to concentrate on them.
You choose to be a pioneer in this domain.
Why? Why do you do that?
Oh, that's easy.
That's easy to answer.
You know, Israel pre-high tech,
it's like the covid-19, pre and post.
Nothing will be the same.
But much more. Okay?
I hope, much more than that.
Israel pre-high tech, in the legal sense,
in the legal profession, was something
that's not going to change.
The larger clients, where they are
at that point,
I was a young lawyer,
there was no other field
where you can start
with smallest client ever.
Like, to intrapreneurs, and turn into
within two years, to have a huge client,
the largest in the firm.
And this is exactly what happened,
to a few of our clients.
So, for me, it was easy.
I was young enough those days
to adapt to the change.
So, we actually, it was natural
to stay where it's low hanging fruit
in the legal profession at that time,
which is the fruits nowadays
are much higher.
That I can assure you.
Yeah.
So, now is there, I mean,
let's say, you're now looking
at new opportunities
and let's say, you have new founders.
I mean, I'm looking at myself.
As I start a company,
I don't have the funds to go
and pay a lawyer and pay a legal firm,
and the caliber of Shibolet,
yet I want to have the best caliber
because I truly believe in my business
and I truly believe of where I'm going
and then my fundraising skills.
So, what adaptations are there
for the tech scene
that might be a little different
than any other industry
in terms of partnering with a firm
like Shibolet to work together?
Is it the same as other industries?
Or, is it a little bit different?
Okay. So, I think that we started
with the right foot in the sense.
The fact that things move very fast
in the high tech scene allows us
to basically do things that are unheard of
in other fields of the legal industry.
So, we have programs of fees
that are actually arranged
for start phase.
So, if we believe in your startup,
so, we are actually, in most cases,
the first investors in your startup.
If you are an entrepreneur,
you come to the lawyer.
Lawyer in many cases,
is just the first station that you park.
And because this is the first advice
and it should be the first advice
that you get.
And in order to avoid from mistakes.
Later on at that time, you are in the most
vulnerable stage in your career,
it's easy to make mistakes.
It's difficult to recover
because you are too weak at that point.
So, that's the reason that
we are actually equipped to take over
all the stuff of those startups
that we believe in.
And it's not easy, actually.
So, we look at the team.
It's not easy to filter.
We use our best senses
and we do lots of mistakes.
Because we are not a better investors
than any other investor.
And we all do 90% mistakes.
Sorry?
How is your due diligence
compared to that of venture capitalists?
We are not into
the technology side at all.
So, we look at the people.
We look at their background.
We hear the story. And if we need,
we take advice from friends
that are more into the technology side.
Or, we talked with potential investors
and we hear from them.
And sometimes we just,
we feel the personality.
You need actually to try
to locate the winners.
That's the issue.
It's people at that point.
So, we don't have
all the tools in the world,
but we have our experience.
And in many cases, we do it in teams.
So, I have a partner who is coming to me,
Look, I have this young startup.
It's in the area of so and so.
And they want to do this and this.
And I'm actually, I'm not sure.
So, sometimes I meet with them again.
Sometimes we talk.
We do a little bit of due diligence
about the team.
That's it.
That's what we have.
We are doing the best
with what we have at that point.
Okay. That's incredible.
And what excites you most in this job?
Is it more the early stage entrepreneurs?
Is it the bigger clients
that they grow to?
Where are you on the spectrum?
Actually, all over it.
There is a lot of interest in partner.
And I look at me, us, as partners
of the entrepreneurs.
That's what we are.
We are with them in the trenches.
We feel the task, we are there.
So, with them, it's in the beginning,
you feel, you create something.
You are a creator.
You bring value.
Other value than what they have.
Which is a lot of experience and so forth.
And they bring their innocence,
which is very important
for a stuff like this, right?
Right.
So, that's at that stage.
But you know what?
What's interesting in the tech area
is that,
no matter how mature
is the technology company,
they always struggle for life.
They are struggling.
So, in many cases,
the lawyer is the only friend,
true friend of the CEO.
What does that mean?
Because I'm imagining a company
that the deal fell through.
Maybe like, a big customer
is no longer a paying customer,
or, they are having a hard time
raising their series As,
so, what do you mean
that you are the only friend of the CEO
or that you're in there with the trenches?
Because it's hard for me to imagine
that a legal firm,
being a friend of the CEO,
it seems like it's not
a friendship relationship.
It's much more of a formal relationship.
Okay. Look, this is the difference
in I think, at least,
in the way we do lawyering.
That there is an issue of chemistry
with your lawyer.
You need to trust the lawyer.
The advice that the lawyer gives you.
And the fact in many cases,
look, if a client's leaves,
you can't do anything, right?
When you are a lawyer.
But the question, whether to go
and do haircuts in salaries,
or to do layoffs, for example,
any other person in the company
has its own interests, right?
You are not interested.
You are just there.
You are his adviser.
So, this is a very unique position.
And this is one of the most
fascinating things about being the lawyer
for entrepreneurs, or CEOs, whoever.
That's the take.
In other industries, it's not like that.
The pace is very different.
Managements are figure in many cases.
With technology companies, even the CEO
or the most experienced person,
at least in the Israeli arena,
has done three M&As in his life.
Right. Right.
Me, I did 300. You see?
So, that's a big difference. Right?
Right. So, I greatly enjoy this.
So, first of all, it sounds to me
that another key difference
from what you're explaining then
what a VC might have, is in the terms
of the risk assessment.
So, the risk that you're taking on
as a firm, when you take on to,
to entrepreneurs or to engineers
from the Technion or whatever,
it's a different risk
than what a VC might take
when they're making
their one out of six investment.
So, a VC might make
six investments a year.
But you're able to take 60 clients a year
or perhaps even more.
And so, you're seeing many more deals
and you're obviously seeing
many more success and failure stories.
And I have to ask then,
if you're seeing so many of these deals,
both the successes and failures,
there must be some patterns that start
coming together again,
whether it is pitfalls in the early stage,
pitfalls in the late stage.
Maybe common successes
or common traits of an entrepreneur
that are among on the successful ones.
But what have you been observing
in your years?
I think that there are endless factors.
That's reality.
And it's very easy to fail.
So, there are a million reasons to fail.
And so, only if all the stars are aligned
that this is very rare,
then you see a big success.
But let's move from early stage.
Early stage,
when you are just the first team,
It should be a coherent team.
And the team should be in most cases,
very clearly defined.
There is a technology guy.
There is a business guy.
And they should actually
be work well together in the sense that
the qualities of one are making for
the disadvantages of the other.
And you can actually,
if you are a little bit into people,
you understand them and you see that.
You see that the conversation flows
and things work.
Yep.
And at that point,
it's very important to clear each of the
entrepreneurs, founders at that point,
that they are the founders, right?
So, their role to make sure
that they understand,
and they set expectations,
and so forth.
So, and it's easy at that point
to make a mistake.
Not to define things.
Work three months, and then
three months or six months down the road,
discover actually, you are not aligned.
Like waterfall. Yup.
Yes. And one goes away,
and the other is staying there.
Doesn't have the rights to the technology.
The other one is fighting for shares
if there will be a company,
and then everything is just lost.
Do you see a lot of pre-emptive conflicts
in regards to shares, equity, salary, IP?
Is there too much of that,
of pre-emptive conflicts
that are just stalling and not letting
the entrepreneur continue?
Too many.
I'm not sure what is too many.
But I can tell you that, I would say that,
in about 25% the quarter of the cases,
that's the issue.
Now, let's add the first stage
or the next stage, is the investors.
Their identity.
They're easy to make mistakes.
You will take onboard the wrong guys,
and all of a sudden, when you go
to the next level of investors,
you are stuck.
They are making troubles.
They make your life miserable.
Do you advise or do you provide opinions
on the term sheets
that the entrepreneur receives
in terms of the future of the company?
So, for example, if I receive a term sheet
for an investor in a seed
that wants preferred stock
and wants a board seat and etc, etc,
do you sometimes come in and say,
"Michael, just be be careful."
"I've seen this thing before."
"And I'm not happy with the way
it's gonna go in the next rounds."
Yes. Sure. This is basic.
And we are trying, first,
in the tech world,
and this is the DNA
that actually we try to convey
to everyone on the team is,
there is no business issue or legal issue.
Everything is relevant to us.
So, when I see a term sheet,
I give my input to the entrepreneur,
assuming that I'm the advisor
for the entrepreneur, on everything.
The identity or the way
the investor behaves,
the term sheet,
the terms of term sheet, the future,
what is reflected,
if these are the terms that are asked
by the investor and so forth.
So, I'm trying to really be
as meaningful as possible in this sense
and not give legal comments.
Legal comments,
every five years of lawyer can give.
So, my added value is not there.
And we are trying to do
even more than that.
Look, we have a team
which is business development
for clients
Because we, all of a sudden,
a couple of years ago discovered,
we see a mountain of information
that can assist entrepreneurs
and investors.
And in most law firms,
no one is doing anything with that.
Right.
So, we have a team of three people
that sit on that data and try to assist.
So, we try to give input really deeper
than just the term sheet.
Even to add with additional investors
and so forth.
Wow.
It's one of the 300 M&As. So, it's okay.
Lior, this is all incredible.
Young entrepreneur,
I'm going to start my own company soon.
What are the things that I should be
most concerned about or excited about
as I start my journey?
When is the first touch point
that I need to make with a firm
like Shibolet or some other legal firm?
And what is the number one thing
to keep in mind?
Because, as you're saying
this is not just,
I'm not just asking for Shibolets
to incorporate me,
I'm asking for a partnership.
I'm asking for them to come with me
on this journey.
And I want them to be
in the trenches with me,
so I better have good chemistry with them.
Right.
So, I think that to the right point is
at the first minute that you have,
like usually it's a team, right,
of two or three people,
so, once that the core team,
the founders to be the founders,
agree that they have a good idea,
that they are determined
to push through together,
that is the right time to come to us,
or, to any other lawyer.
So, as soon as you're agreeing
that you're gonna go into this
10-year journey, into this marathon,
and you know that you're working together,
then, this is the right touch point.
Right. Right.
Wonderful.
Any later, you may be wasting time
or doing a mistake
that will be detrimental later on.
So, that's the reason
that we are the first stop, actually.
Before you come into any other.
Because, as far as I was concerned,
today, you can incorporate $500
in Delaware online,
and you can start your journey,
and you can start writing your product.
And maybe,
when you go to that pre-seed stage
and then you need to quickly
get a term sheet,
and then you go and you quickly find
the first legal firm that says hi to you,
but you're saying, no, this is
actually a long term investment.
This is a partnership.
One of the most important partnerships
you're gonna have
in the lifetime of your company.
And so, thank you for teaching that.
Lior, right before we leave,
I want to thank you again
for your generosity with your time
and your inspiration.
And the 25 years of experience
you bring with you,
I think that's incredible.
And I've learned so much.
And I'm sure that anybody listening
has learned so much.
But I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Okay. So, actually,
I will use I think, one word.
I'm a multi disciplinary.
And that's with respect to personality
and qualifications or talent.
So, that's me.
I'm around person.
I love it. I love it.
Leon, toda raba.
It came out as an American. Toda raba.
Toda raba.
My pleasure.
Every conversation is changing.
Hebrew and English,
it's becoming impossible.
So, I do the same.
My pleasure.
There you go. All right.
And hopefully we get to work together
on n venture that I hope to create
very soon.
Very happy to, Michael.
Take care. Enjoy.
Bye bye.
Bye.